allez directions jouer les tours à
présent où la pharmacie de la Rabière
vient de rouvrir 5 mois après l'incendie
qui avait ravagé le centre commercial
cet incendie était survenu fin juin lors
des émeutes qui ont suivi la mort de
Naël début octobre les élus avaient donc
voté la mise en place d'un bâtiment
provisoire pour accueillir la pharmacie
en attendant la construction de ces
nouveaux locaux pour 2026 l'officine a
donc rouvert aujourd'hui dans un module
installé devant le bâtiment calciné un
retour qui était très attendu par les
habitant du quartier Clémence
d'sque c'est dans ce bâtiment modulaire
que la pharmacie De laarabière a rouvert
ce matin les plus fidèles clients
étaient déjà au rendez-vous bonjour on
est cont de vous voir oui c'est chouette
oui oui on attendait même depuis un
petit moment voilà ça fait 50 ans que je
viens à la pharmacie ici je ne voulais
pas les laisser tomber coup ça nous
manqu quand même parce que en plus nous
on n'est pas loin alors et puis quand un
certain âge on a souvent besoin du
pharmacien alors on est vraiment content
que c'est rouvert aujourd'hui on est
très très très content ça fait du bien
ça fait du
bien les discussions vont bon train car
pendant 5 mois et demi les habitants du
quartier ont dû changer leurs habitudes
suite à l'incendie de leur pharmacie
désormais c'est retour à la normale pour
le plus grand bonheur des usagers et des
équipes de l'officine ah depuis ce matin
on est baigné par voyez plein de plein
de personnes qui viennent nous apporter
sp voilà on a des petits qu techniqu
mais c'est normal tout est en train de
se mettre en place mais voilà tout va
bien les dégâts de la pharmacie ont été
estimés à près de 15000 € l'officine et
les commerces adjacents déménageront
dans une nouvelle zone commerciale juste
en face à l'horizon